[Musica]
passiamo dal pollo al salame vede tempo
e tra un po anche ora di di pranzare ma
intanto noi siamo al bar di solomeo
vedete il borgo alle nostre spalle e in
questo bar a questo bar con questo tipo
di ingredienti ma con le persone in
primo luogo e poi con questi strumenti
ni che sono piuttosto innovativi ma
tutto sommato ancora validi questi
quattro libri il nostro assieme a un po
d'amici trascorreva le sue serate
giovanili la la mettiamo in conto alla
formazione brunello il bar del paese
sì devo dire che il barra è stata in
qualche maniera la mia università perché
io ho vissuto i primi 15 anni di vita in
campania non avevamo la luce di tasca
mia stata un'avventura bellissima non
avevamo televisione quindi niente mi
faceva sempre in flessione mio nonno che
diceva speriamo che 10 mandi la giusta
acqua il giusto vento il giusto sole
quindi questa grande
del giusto quindi questa grande idea del
prodotto del profitto
il tono in un modo giusto poi siamo
andati a vivere vicino alla città il mio
babbo è andata la roma volare in
fabbrica e devo dire che spesso veniva
umiliato e offeso e io non ho mai capito
da lì perché si debba umiliare un essere
umano
ecco parliamo di lavoro flaiano della
tua concezione di lavoro perché molto a
che vedere la tua formazione con il tuo
modo di rapportarti oggi con i tuoi
collaboratori collaboratori vuol dire
proprio etimologicamente coloro che
lavorano insieme
sì ho avuto ho vissuto questi dieci anni
di vita di barking non è che lavorava al
bar
però ho vissuto lì e devo dire che al
bar trust lo trovi sempre qualcuno che
ascolta le tue pene e mentre progettavo
la mia vita facendo più che altro
scherzi perché ho fatto tre anni
ingegneria facendo il solo esame
però mi sono divertito da morire e poi
ho avuto questa idea di far cascio il
colorato ma il sogno della mia vita che
è partito verso 17 anni quando una frase
di kant
mi ha illuminato la vita sentito più o
meno che cosa dice
agisci considerando l'umanità sia per te
stesso che per gli altri non come
semplice mezzo ma come nobile fine
quindi il nobile fine l'umanità
quindi da livers 17 anni mi sono detto
non so cosa farò nella vita ma ora
vorrei farlo per la dignità umana e poi
avuto questa idea di far cashmere
colorato ma non sono qui a raccontarvi
questo perché io volevo da una parte far
profitti con etica dignità e morale non
so se ci riusciamo e da un'altra parte
in qualche maniera
questi profitti che servissero
all'impresa perché fosse più solida a me
personalmente ma vivono un piccolo paese
ai ragazzi che lavorano con noi è
un'altra importante ad abbellire
l'umanità come dice adriano imperatore
mi sento responsabile delle bellezze del
mondo
perché voi giovani dovete ritrovare il
grande amore di essere responsabile
delle bellezze del mondo
c'è qualcosa che è venuto un po per gli
amanti bene brunelli dovresti alzare un
po all'archetto in modo tale che si
senta meglio ditemi voi adesso sei
sentite bene quindi
sapete che cosa voglio dirvi io anche
quando mi sono messo a os onorato la mia
babbo scherzosamente dirgli caro papà
perché noi ci chiamiamo babbo
io vorrei fare pullover di cachemire lui
non conosceva nella parola pullover né
cashmere e quindi sapete sapete che va
detto che dio ti protegga che riotta
aiuti
avete capito però la differenza adesso
se invece noi genitori essendo sapienti
i nostri figli vengono da noi e ci
dicono che hanno un progetto particolare
noi vi diciamo chi ti dà i soldi dove lo
fi o colmano lo produce
in realtà sapete ho i miei stimatissimi
giovani
qual è il grande errore che noi abbiamo
fatto il primo facendovi capire che noi
eravamo più bravi di voi non ci credete
e il secondo ancora più grave non studi
e quindi andrai a lavorare al lavoro
abbiamo imputato tutte le colpe cioè
abbiamo tolto dignità morale ed
economica da lì dobbiamo ripartire da
questi 30 anni di crisi di civiltà e non
parlo di crisi economica passati quindi
del passato non parliamo più perché mi
piacerebbe parlare di oggi di questa
rinascita spirituale morale e civile
etica
religiosa ed anche economica perché
viviamo un nuovo mondo anche se forse
senza forse il miglior mondo della
nostra umanità torello ci arriviamo tra
un momento a ragionare sul fatto che le
rivoluzioni vere e il rinascimento vero
non abolisce il passato ma in realtà
oblitera il presente richiama il passato
e si proietta nel futuro ci torniamo tra
momento però prima mi piacerebbe che tu
ci portasse a solomeo cioè in quel borgo
feci dicessi la materialità della vita
così come la è tessuta nella relazione
con i tuoi collaboratori
ti porto in un altro se vuoi villaggio
in un altro borgo modo da costituire una
sorta di parallelo a valdagno
nei primi anni dell'ottocento nasce una
grande impresa
i fratelli marzotto e i fratelli
marzotto non pensano semplicemente a una
successione di telai ma impiantano il
teatro ci sono le case per i dipendenti
ci sono gli asili le scuole c'è tutto
quello che costituisce un luogo sociale
sì questo è il paesino di mia moglie io
sono nato in un piccolo paese ho sempre
pensato che la vita nel borgo sia
leggermente migliore come diceva jean
jacques rousseau nel 1765 sentiti che
bella quando dice dobbiamo tornare nei
borghi ridiscutere riprogettare
l'umanità mi sembra il momento giusto
in realtà io volevo solo che gli esseri
umani lavori lavorassero luoghi
leggermente migliori perché guardate che
lavorare per mille euro al mese i lavori
spesso ripetitivi e abbastanza difficile
e volevo che questi esseri umani
lavorassero in condizioni migliori e che
cosa facciamo in azienda siamo 1.600
persone si entra tutti alle 8 del
mattino si lavora su luna il pranzo è
importantissimo perché nella nostra
cultura
poi si lavora dalle 230 sino alle 5 30
non si può essere
messi dopo le 5 30 non si può essere
connessi sabato e domenica perché io
credo che come diceva san benedetto
dobbiamo curare ogni giorno la mente con
lo studio l'anima con la preghiera e il
lavoro ritrovare un equilibrio perché
guardate io credo che quel mal
dell'anime a chi ha sempre colpito
l'essere umano
in questo momento questo rumore
informatico di fondo che abbiamo
appesantisce il mal dell'anima e questo
fa sì che viviamo un'atmosfera un po un
po speciale sotto il profilo umano
dobbiamo ripartire da qui dobbiamo
ripartire dal essere leggermente
migliori come dice sant'agostino
alza gli occhi al cielo che la vita ti
parra migliore dobbiamo tornare a
parlare con noi stessi dobbiamo tornare
a parlarci
che cos'era il bar era quello che era
uscito dice chiama la sua pole mossa
dibattito discussioni politica donne
economia religioni come erano
affascinanti queste discussioni e lì
dove tu impari in qualche maniera anche
a capire l'essere umano
questa l'arte di farsi voler bene noi
abbiamo bisogno di persone perbene
abbiamo bisogno di ritrovarci nei grandi
valori della vita perché stiamo vivendo
una grande rinascita mondiale
sapete che cosa facciamo noi in azienda
dal primo del 2016
non guardiamo più nessun documento degli
anni passati e guardiamo esclusivamente
un mondo a venire
c'è un'espressione bellissima per voi
giovani di volterra che vi si addice
se tutti il tuo tempo non accetti
cambiamenti forse prenderà è la parte
peggiore
io voglio accettare i cambiamenti vorrei
però che governassimo in qualche maniera
questa nuova era informatica perché
spesso credo che ci travolga in qualche
maniera l'anima siamo presi siamo un po
pressi di cosa abbiamo paura dico a voi
giovani non a doppia non dovete avere
paura non dovete svolgere le spalle alla
povertà
è un altro grande tema guardate che la
fiamma del progresso è sempre arte
sempre è sempre lì affascinante allora
voi giovani perché non vi tornate a
riprendervi l'amore per per gestire
custodire questo secolo
ma chi siete voi giovani custodi no i
cui non proprietari le sentinelle siete
sentinelle nell'umanità
riscoprite certi valori tornate come
dice adriano non ho mai conosciuto
qualcuno che dopo un complimento non si
sia sentito migliore dobbiamo tornare a
stringerci la mano dobbiamo tornare a
stimarci indipendentemente dalla lingua
indipentemente dalla razza e vi dico una
cosa importantissima
abbiamo abolito da noi la parola
globalità noi vogliamo essere un'azienda
universale che ha rispetto per qualsiasi
essere umano di qualsiasi nazione di
qualsiasi lingua di qualsiasi cultura
da lì dobbiamo ripartire ed avere una
integrazione attiva
con questa marea di gente che che va in
giro per l'umanità per conoscerlo ma età
perché sarà la più grande migrazione
nell'umanità quindi io mi rivolgo a voi
giovani siate speciali tornata ad
investire nella dignità morale ed
economica dell'essere umano vi dico una
cosa carina
guardate i primi di giugno faccio al mio
paesino una riunione dove ho invitato
chiaramente i giovani umbri che vogliono
venire e progettare qualcosa di speciale
cioè li chiamo riunione dei giovani
innovatori del terzo millennio
manufatturieri perché io credo che noi
siamo una nazione di manufatti abbiamo
bisogno di manufatti muovi geniali
creativi quindi ripartite da questo
ripartite dal coraggio di alessandro
magno che a 17 anni parte per
conquistare
vita guardando tutti i giorni il mare
brunello parliamo un attimo di paura che
è un concetto che tu hai appena
richiamate bellissimo
ecco vi vorrei leggere due qualche riga
di questo libro che si intitola venezia
minima e che è stato scritto da uno dei
più grandi romanzieri balcanici predrag
matvejevic predrag vuol dire pietro e
sottolineo questo semplicemente per dire
che quel che ci può apparire distante in
realtà predrag in effetti che ho che
roba è
eppure se ci guardiamo dentro lo
troviamo molto molto prossimo noi mi
sono fermato di recente sul canal grande
nell'autunno avanzato di sera dei
palazzi che vi si affacciano solo pochi
erano illuminati i più erano sprofondati
nella penombra c'era dentro ancora
qualcuno perché i loro abitanti i loro
eredi dovrebbero averli abbandonati
la paura si insinua in queste domande o
forse quelle incertezza del futuro che
sentono i veneziani e quelli che amano
venezia incertezza del futuro allora
siamo in presenza di una delle più belle
città del mondo di un deposito
straordinario di un patrimonio che ci è
stato consegnato e abbiamo paura come
andate mio nonno ha fatto la guerra mio
babbo fatto la guerra la fame la
dittatura
pensate solo a 30 anni fa come venivano
trattati i gay i bambini le donne
l'umanità è migliorata in un modo
affascinante quindi vi è in atto una
sorta di declino della violenza ma anche
una sorta di declino del consumismo
approdi utilizzo delle cose come dice
sicuro
l'essere umano deve risolvere due
problemi il mal dell'anno
e utilizzare ciò che la terra ci dà
senza consumarla
ma intorno ai primi del cinquecento
quando tornano i mercanti dall'america e
portano pomodoro mais e patate solo per
quello devo dire che ci hanno fatto un
dono immenso pomodori patate guardate
l'europa incomincia aver paura e lì il
mio grande maestro igenio erasmo da
rotterdam dice un mio signore
fammi vivere un'altra ventina d'anni
perché sta arrivando al secolo d'oro
come voi giovani non potete immaginare
che sta arrivando il secolo d'oro non
sarà più il secolo del tiranno
guardate che ci sono stati momenti della
storia dopo dopo dove dopo il tiranno
arriva l'uomo illuminato dopo nerone
arriva il grande vespasiano doppio
cimone arriva il grande pericle e
illumina l'umanità con che cosa dicendo
unicamente noi ad atene facciamo così
sempre senza senza imporre qualcosa di
speciale
voi giovani dovete tornare a
riappropriarsi della politica della
bella politica
quali sono i grandi ideali la bella
politica
la bella famiglia la spiritualità alla
religione
sotto il profilo spirituale religioso
credo che questo papa affascinante
almeno per me vi ha fatto un discorso
l'altro giorno incredibile che appena
eletto ci chiede di essere custodi del
creato
nessuna ingerenza nella specialità di
ogni essere umano sia esso ateo
cristiano ebreo pensate quale meraviglia
allora possiamo avere meno paura
possiamo affrontare il mondo in un modo
diverso
possiamo darci la mano guardarci con
dignità possiamo tornare a rispettare le
leggi
e voi giovani avete l'obbligo di
costruire le nostre meraviglie e antici
che gli antichi greci di con una cosa
bellissima
se il portone di casa tua sarà pulita la
tua città sarà pulita è nostro dovere
lasciarti una città più bella
come l'abbiamo avuta la verità a me
piacerebbe che voi
da domattina riprogettate un nuovo mondo
sentendovi responsabili di quello che
fate
alzando gli occhi al cielo come si dice
sant'agostino la vite più facile è
migliore e di non aver paura perché
stiamo vivendo non so in che se il mondo
se il più bel momento dell'umanità ma il
miglior mondo sino ad oggi verificatosi
guardate io sono affascinato e devo dire
la verità sono affascinato perché ho 63
anni forse this ma questo è un vecchio
affascinato io sono affascinato però
sentitevi custodi perché sentirsi
custodi significa costruire da custodi
custodire da custodi da sentinelle
quindi riappropriatevi dei grandi valori
dell'essere umano
la bella politica la famiglia la
spiritualità o la religione
io starei qui a parlarvi tutto il giorno
devo controllare lì le ore perché lei
minuti perché sono corti veronello
parliamo un momento anche di cosa
c'entra la bellezza nel tuo fare impresa
una volta mi ha raccontato che è
comperato dei capannoni per poterli
abbattere o comunque modificare come ma
c'è sempre lì una bella espressione di
adriano imperatore quando a un certo
punto dice mi sento responsabili delle
bellezze del mondo
quindi lui dice se io e edificherò
qualcosa di speciale
l'umanità sarà abbellita e questo è
stato sempre un po l'obiettivo della mia
vita io nel restaurare questo paesino
devo dire ci ho messo una ventina d'anni
di solo abbiamo costruito solo un teatro
interrato ispirato al mio stimato grande
palladio poi nella valle c'erano dei
capannoni industriali costruiti negli
anni settanta meno carini e ho cercato
di trasformarlo in un grande parco
perché perché io credo che il 70 per
cento degli esseri umani vivono nelle
periferie e noi dobbiamo lavorare i due
giovani avete da responsabili
di lavorare per far sì che queste
periferie tornino ad essere amabili ed
essere belle gatte con le città perché i
centri storici sono belli ben restaurati
e noi ora dobbiamo tornare nelle
periferie e restaurarle e ripartire da
lì un tema di bellezza ma per la verità
è anche un tema che attiene al tuo
modello di impresa perché tu hai deciso
di farlo non a milano dove tutto come se
fosse un grande magnete viene attirato
mai deciso di farlo la perché c'è la
possibilità oggi in questa stagione il
nuovo rinascimento di fare bene le cose
sostanzialmente ovunque ma diciamo che
siamo connessi e quindi perché non
possiamo lavorare in un piccolo borgo
piuttosto che una città piuttosto che di
una periferia
io credo che però abbiamo bisogno di
ritrovarci e per ritrovarci abbiamo
bisogno anche di stare insieme per
discutere e nelle periferie non sempre
vi è un luogo di ritrovo che era il bar
è vero scusate mio stimate donne ma era
solo per uomini
io avevo solo un'amica che faceva la
prostituta e veniva la sera a mezzanotte
ma era affascinante perché io avevo
diciotto diciannove anni e lei mi
parlava delle sue pene dell'anima
avevano 35 a danni quindi lì mi sono
rimaste un po nel cuore queste pene
quindi epoca il bar e luogo di pena di
gioia dove comunque c'è un equilibrio e
dove si discute di tutto rinascimento
ragioniamo del rinascimento perché tu
dici che siamo al principio di un nuovo
rinascimento vedete lorenzo il magnifico
un certo punto intorno al 1870 mette
nello stesso tavolo da pranzo il
giovanissimo michelangelo marsilio
ficino che fa il filosofo mette magari
un occhio chiunque però unendo arte
mestieri da alle arti e ai mestieri
la stessa importanza noi dobbiamo
riscoprire la dignità morale ed
economica dei mestieri le arti ce le
hanno per loro natura e e credo che gli
ultimi tre o quattro anni questo si sta
risvegliando perché non possiamo fare un
bellissimo mestiere dignitoso e avere
anche la giusta remunerazione
fino a qualche tempo fa in realtà
pensavamo che questi mestieri dovessero
farli i figli degli altri
ecco perché abbiamo tolto dignità ma
adesso qualcosa sta cambiando nei
giovani c'è un fascino diverso
voi giovani gettate meno cose guardate
meglio colui che è in difficoltà
io ritrovo sufficientemente affascinanti
devo dire brunello credo che abbiamo più
o meno esaurito nel nostro tempo è però
scritto spiace un po anche anche a penso
anche a loro
ma questo qui penso che gli stia anche
indicare che sostanzialmente ora di
pranzo senti brunello un ultimo elemento
che ha a che fare con l'investimento
principale che ciascuno di noi è
chiamato a fare su di sé e torniamo ai
libri e alla necessità dello studio
guardate io non ho studiato niente devo
dir la verità perché avevo il 6 politico
ha negli anni 70 quindi km peso 40 su 60
cioè niente ingegneria tre anni un esame
però devo dire che adriano imperatori mi
dice i libri mi hanno indicato la via
della vita e da grande si dice la vita
mi ha fatto comprendere il contenuto dei
libri e oggi se mi domandate la cosa un
po speciale per me sono i libri ma lì ci
sono le delle espressioni che ci
cambiano ci cambia la vita quando boezio
condannato a morte intorno al 500 dopo
cristo nella sua meravigliosa
consolazione della filosofia conclude
dicendo o beato genere umano se i vostri
animi fossero governare
dalla morte governa al cielo quindi alla
fine di tutto io vorrei trasmettere
serenità gioia passione amore per il
divertimento e immaginando appunto che
il nostro amato universo illumina il
nostro cammino e grazie
e bello
grazie